le cadeau de mars et le nouvel album
d'astérix 41 ans après sa naissance dans
pilote ces rixes revient pour une 31e
aventure et l'on promet déjà des
millions d'exemplaires pour ce nouvel
album d'albert uderzo intitulé la
traviata ce reportage sophie jouer dès
10 heures les rotatives ont tourné à
plein régime pendant deux mois pour
livrer ce 31e album 8 millions
d'exemplaires une véritable invasion
voilà enfin les pages tant attendu où
les femmes sont à l'honneur une belle
romaine la traviata infiltre le village
gaulois en se faisant passer pour
falbala et puis surprise les mamans
d'astérix et d'obélix débarque le jour
de leur anniversaire l'occasion de
reprendre en main ses deux vieux garçon
qui ne sont pas décidés à se marier ils
ont des contrats avec moi oui non pas
grâce aux marées et ça c'est tout à fait
normal alors que ça serait plus des
héros ah vous voyez un héros marié
pierre dans ses pantoufles allait courir
le guilledou avec sérieux c'est lui le
chef albert en personne qui a concocté
le phénoménal lancement de ce nouvel
album
une conférence de presse en février à
rennes rebaptisé condate où l'on
apprenait seulement le titre de
l'ouvragé le budget de publicité
millions de francs un investissement à
la hauteur des bénéfices attendus le
succès eu des réseaux est tombé dedans
quand il était petit 300 millions
d'albums ont été vendus depuis la
première apparition d'astérix temps
pilote en 59 uderzo pour le dessin vous
signez pour le scénario on a la chance
de faire quelque chose qui plaît au
public qui amuse le public qui nous
amuse aussi alors il n'y a pas de raison
de s'arrêter là
et l' aventure se poursuit malgré la
disparition de goscinny l'image du petit
gaulois étaient déclinés à l'infini une
machine assez ster qui rapporte 120
millions de chiffre d'affaires chaque
année par toutatis
ces gars là ont trouvé de ce 13e la
potion magique aaa